the Shaquille O'Neal partnering with
Frosted Flakes mission tiger an effort
to improve access to middle school
sports that have been impacted by more
than 340 thousand student athletes
nationwide and Shaq joins us on the
program
good morning Shaq how are you I want to
talk to McLovin he's always here for you
Shaq what's up jack one of these days
Shaq's gonna realize that Paulie is
McLovin in Shaq's mind but that's okay
are you a cowboy fan I sure now real a
real Cowboys fan I want to dive in a
cowboy pass that's head-to-toe Jones
Roger Staubach Emmitt Smith of course my
go urban neon Deon yes I will always be
a cowboy and do you go to games no I'm
living with the games that I met Jerry
Jones last show our medical cover
thought but I saw him less and he's that
man
you need to come to a game like this
Sarah would love to come again but I
don't want to Bobby well I will so I
will get to a game one day what's good
to have you on there's a lot of things
to talk about here I don't know if
you're watching the Jordan documentary
we had Patrick Ewing on and Reggie
Miller and they said this isn't any fun
for us it's fun for you guys to watch it
but is there any enjoyment watching this
I think it just solidifies the argument
about who's the best player ever
we all think I think the fair thing says
we should probably break it down arrows
hunter was the best player ever well
Michael Jordan by thought stuff that
he's done I don't I don't see anybody
being close to that you know he's a 10
there's a lot of settings and aids out
there but there's no nines or tens and
he's just I actually got to watch I
actually got to see the end of it
personally I want a lot of money by by
asking people who was the last team to
beat him in the playoff situation
the other people forget what we did and
94 95 but their comeback is oh he was
just eating he wasn't ready he wore
number 45 it wasn't the real Mike but
I'm enjoying it because it just brings
that flashbacks in and also especially
when they were battling Detroit who just
this this maybe remember how physical
the gang was and that's the game I like
to play this game I'm watching now yeah
how many would Mike average and with
today's rules Mike it is peak let's say
Mike 1991-92 how many points 45 45
easily but what would you average today
[Laughter]
and of course the Lakers with you and
Kobe would beat Michael Jordan Scottie
Pippen right Shaq's Orlando Magic beat
Mike's Bulls that was they they won Game
six in Chicago I think that year and
then a year later your final game with
Orlando yes and then you went to LA
after that but Mike the Bulls ended your
magic career yes so good okay you know
we beat them before we were confident
but they put it away very quickly they
let him know that last year this is a
different team and they sure this one
made some different could you imagine if
there and I don't know if this is true
or not but I think Magic Johnson was
talking about on Entertainment Tonight
that maybe there is a sort of a last
year documentary on Kobe with the Lakers
have you heard anything about that yeah
because I was wondering it you guys
didn't have any of this all access when
when you were with the Lakers when you
were winning there's a lot of footage
out there I also I don't know if you
found this out or you heard this but are
we gonna how
are we to having an NBA team in Las
Vegas in your opinion I think really
close no I'm sure the other day I know
there's a lot of well not allowed to
there's a couple teams that are looking
to relocate I don't have the exact team
so exactly probably can say anyway I
know for a fact it's a couple of teams
that are you know in a couple investors
out there looking to purchase teams and
they want to move came to certain areas
and Las Vegas be one of those various
yeah I heard Memphis was one of the
teams prime for that possibility why
don't you take some of that money you
make from the general and become an
owner I did forget that yes now they
could use you yeah yeah player owner
when's the last time you played a game
against against uh it was me and my
youngest son I guess you're even one of
those partners and how's your son doing
how's his health is good ready to go
gonna be going to my alma mater LSU of
he's gonna you know get back on track
are you eating frosted flakes right now
how do you know that I can I can hear
you crunching do you have a camera in my
house I'm like it sounds like you're
having breakfast right that's great
tell us about the frosted flakes mission
tiger here Leslie is I wanted to partner
with all you tiger
so this is Sara I grew up off I mean no
more of that process on this initiative
to help give up middle middle school
kids that
that's sports you know we're gonna do a
donation will help this to school in
Philly build a court on the school
grounds to save dedicated space the guys
are playing train and we're gonna give
their teams all new uniforms and train
equip and we're going to cover the
facility close to avoid cancer pretzels
time to cancer or kilos of frosted
flakes if they start this initiative
like the things gonna be enough to have
I've got a perfect place that all my
life who should be matter they weren't
on the Dream Team you or Isaiah Isaiah
cuz I think he definitely been on that
you like Laettner was chosen over you
right yeah but I don't the way he he was
used I wouldn't have been happy with
that what do you mean that I wasn't
gonna have to just sit in the bench and
get mad one or two minutes yeah if Ernie
shows up with Charles and Kenny six feet
apart at your doorstep but only two can
come in who are the two that get to come
in not letting Charles in huh it's great
to talk to you I hope you're being safe
and good luck with frosted flakes
mission tiger great to talk to you as
always check Thank You chef